نقل الى رام الله من هناك معنا وليد
العمري مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد كنت تحدثنا
عن القلق في داخل اسرائيل من انطلاق هذه
الجلسات كيف يتطور المشهد وايضا ما
الانعكاسات المحتمله لما يحصل في لاهاي
على مجريات الحرب في غزه على الارض
ميدانيا القلق في اسرائيل تعكسه ردات
الفعل في اسرائيل وعلى المستوى الرسمي
ايضا هناك من يتهم السلطه الفلسطينيه
والخارجيه الفلسطينيه بانها قدمت المساعده
في اعداد هذا التقرير الذي قدمته جنوب
افريقيا في لاهاي لا بل ذهب السفير
الاسرائيلي الاسبق لدى جنوب افريقيا الى
اعتبار وكان العلاقه التي كانت الوطيده
بين منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه والمؤتمر
الوطني الافريقي على مدار عقود هي السبب
في انهما كانا شقيقان كما قال يعملان سويه
علما انه في تلك الفتره كانت اسرائيل
حليفه لنظام الابرتهايد الفصل العنصري في
جنوب افريقيا قبل ان يستقر حالها بعد
تحرير نيلسون مانديلا وانصاره الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه وعلى لسان المتحدث باسمها
ذهبت في بيان الى القول بان العالم كان
شاهدا على استعراض نفاق عالمي حسب تعبيرها
حسب تعبير البيان
وان قائم على الكذب والافتراءات العاريه
عن الصحه على حد قولهم وان جنوب افريقيا
تصرفت او وظفت نفسها كذراع قضائيه في خدمه
حماس غير ذلك في المعارضه ايضا المواقف
مشابهه لمواقف الحكومه وكان ر زعيم
المعارضه يائير لبيد من ناحيته هو الاخر
قد هاجم اجتماع هذه المحكمه واعتبر انه
تجني على اسرائيل لانها هي الضحيه على حد
قوله وذهب نواب من الليكود ووزراء اخرين
الى اعتبار ما يجري فيها بانه حدث لا سامي
لا بل بعضهم اتهم المحكمه نفسها محكمه
العدل الدوليه بانها لا ساميه واخرون
هددوا بان من يمس اليهود سيدفع الثمن ردود
الفعل كثيره بهذا الخصوص وكان واضح القلق
بهذا الشان هو ما كان في تصريح رئيس
الحكومه الليله الماضيه عندما خرج في
تصريح مصور باللغه الانجليزيه وكان واضح
بان انه موجه الى محكمه هاي يلقي
المسؤوليه ينفي ان تكون اسرائيل قد تقترف
ما جوني سيد او حرب اباده جماعيه ضد
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه وينفي ان في
نيتها ايه تهجير الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه
واقامه مستوطنات وانها كانت الضحيه ما
يجري في لاهاي مقلق لاسرائيل ايضا لانه
جاء مدعما ببي بالاضافه الى المرافعه
القانونيه التي قدم هذا الفريق وهو ما
متوقع ان ترد عليه اسرائيل غدا في ردها من
خلال طاقم سيقوده البروفيسور مولك شواو
البريطاني اليهودي الصهيوني وهو صاحب اسم
عالمي مع فريق من اربعه خبراء في القانون
وس يذهب حسب ما تسرب عنه اولا الى القول
بان اسرائيل اضطرت على هذه الحرب بعد ما
سيسميه بالمذبح السابع من اكتوبر التي قتل
فيها اكثر من 1200 اسرائيلي واختطف 250
كما سيدعي في في مرافعته بان الاقتباسات
المرفقه مع الشكوى التي قدمتها جنوب
افريقيا قد اخرجت من سياقها حسب تعبيره
وايضا بان هذه التصريحات لا تاتي من اشخاص
هم في دائره القرار في اسرائيل بالاضافه
بطبيعه الحال الى القول ان اسرائيل تحارب
حماس ولا تحارب الشعب الفلسطيني وسيعود
الى ما جرى في السابع من الشهر من شهر
اكتوبر الماضي وواضح بان اسرائيل يمثلها
في هذه المحكمه القاضي هروم براك وهذا
القاضي من ربما رقم واحد في اسرائيل كان
رئيسا لمحكمه العدل الدوليه
لمحكمه المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه وصاحب
اسم عالي لكن اختياره جاء ليس فقط بسبب
خبرته ومهنيته واسمه وانما ايضا لانه هو
من الناجين من المحركه النازيه في الحرب
العالميه الماضيه وسيمثل اسرائيل
بالمرافق شواو وواضح بان هناك اهتمام في
اسرائيل بهذه المحكمه وخشيه من انها
بالفعل ستتخذ قرارا احترازيا بوقف اطلاق
النار وستحول الى المجلس الامن و وهذا
سيكون محرجا للولايات المتحده وان كانوا
في اسرائيل يعتقدون بان واشنطن في نهايه
المطاف ستستخدم حق النقض الفيتو لاسقاطه
اذا لزم الامر طيب وليد في خلال
اي المرافعات التي استمعنا اليها داخل
المحكمه كان هناك طلب من جنوب افريقيا
بضروره تعليق العمليات العسكريه الحفاظ
على الادله في داخل قطاع غزه وتامين وصول
المساعدات الى المواطنين في قطاع غزه
تامين ايضا ربما في مرحله لاحقه وصول ف
فريق قانوني للاستقصاء
و لمتابعه هذه الادله والبراهين كيف من
شان كل ما جرى الحديث به في داخل المحكمه
اليوم ان ينعكس على العمليات العسكريه في
قطاع
غزه بخصوص ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه هذا
الموضوع اشتغل به ايضا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بلينكن وكان من المفروض ان تدخل
اليوم 400 شاحنه او 300 شاحنه حتى الان
ليس واضح ما عدد الشاحنات التي دخلت وكيف
سيتم اليه توزيع هذه المساعدات الامر
الثاني بما يتعلق بالادله وادخال اطقم
دوليه اسرائيل تدرك جيدا انه في نهايه
المطاف ستكون هناك لجنه تحقيق دوليه خاصه
اذا اقرت المحكمه محكمه العدل الدوليه وهي
احدى المؤسسات المهمه للامم المتحده هذه
المنظومه الدوليه بان تاتي وتدخل لتقصي
الحقائق لكن سبقى لاسرائيل ان منعت لجان
تحقيق دوليه من الوصول والدخول والمشاركه
هذه المره قد تاتي اللجنه من منطقه رفح
اذا اتيح لها الدخول اي من داخل الاراضي
المصريه لكن واضح ان اسرائيل قد تعترض على
ذلك كليا لانها لا تريد ان تخرج مدانه من
هذه المحاكمه التي تقف فيها متهمه ب بتهمه
تنفيذ حرب اباده جماعيه بحق الفلسطينيين
في نعم قطاع غزه وهي تريد ان تسوق نفسها
على انها تدافع عن نفسها ولا تشن حربا
بهذا الخصوص اشكرك وليد العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره من رام الله